e
e e
it being 10:00 on the 17th I will call
The Joint fiscal committee meeting to
order and item number one is the
acceptance of minutes of April
19th second motion by representative uh
by Senator dallesandro second by Senator
grade to accept the minutes of April
19th is there any additional Corrections
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I iOS no the minutes
are adopted I'll abstain Mr chairman I
wasn't here thank you one
abstention nothing under old
business under tab
three uh yes I'm I'm just curious given
that we're likely to get a lot more
volume from outside what what are your
thoughts on shutting the windows so that
we can hear a good
idea CU it going just start the program
right
now okay tab three item number 24
1992 consider recommendation proposed to
it by legislative performance audit
oversight committee and I'll recognize
representative rosenal for that
recommendation thank you Mr chairman
there were two two audits that were
discussed that were both adopted
unanimously by The Joint performance uh
audit oversight committee one was to
look at the interplay
between um
DCF and the Bureau of children's
Behavioral Health and the second was to
to a performance audit of the doorways
program and there is a request from
Senator rosemal to approve those
items yes Mr chairman
and the second by Senator
Pearl further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I oppose no those that is
adopted we have a uh consent
calendar that includes Tab four all the
items on Tab four through tab nine there
are four items that have been requested
to be
removed under tab six
uh
2414 Department of Health and Human
Services
24179 Department of Natural and cultural
resources and under Tab 8
24153 Department of Health and Human
Services and
24183 Department of administrative
services and also I will note that item
2481 under Tab 8 has been withdrawn
so how do you wish to proceed with the
consent
calendar
second uh Senator alesandro Mo
representative Edward second that we
approve the rest of the items in with
the exception of those I just mentioned
is there any further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose
no consent calendar is adopted with the
exception of those items first one we'll
move to under tab
six will be FIS
24154 that's Department of Health and
Human
Services good
morning good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services uh good
morning Ian watt uh interim director
division of Public Health
Services representative f is recognized
for a question thank you Mr chair thank
you all for being here so I wonder if
you could just tell me a little bit
about what the newborn Navigator program
is you indicated that it's not a federal
program so there's no federal law behind
it and also and yet it talks about
source of funds or at least it talks
about Tana funds which is a federal
program so maybe just to discuss that
and then let me know how the funding is
working and what the program itself is
and what where where it's based in law
or whatever sure so the the funding
source is is T if is a federal funding
uh Source the program itself is is a
service of best practice services for uh
newborn support So supporting families
with supportive care services uh to
ensure uh the perpetuation of two parent
families Ure safe safe practice with
your families and ensure the family is
well supported by Community Resources so
a either birthing hospital or healthc
care provider May refer uh a child into
uh home visiting Services through the uh
the newborn navigation program uh
newborn Navigator would then work with
the family to ensure that they have
knowledge of safe safe sleep or lead
prevention uh programs may be nutrition
services it may be a referral to other
supportive care services so it's a best
practice in Family Care and and newborn
support the program itself is not you
know federally regulated or federally
specified follow follow up is there any
place on on the DJ's website that talks
but I tried to Google it and I found
some information about it but not
specifically related to the state uh so
I am happy to to follow up with some
resources on it I don't have uh off hand
I don't know if there's anything
specifically on newborn navigator on our
website uh but I'm happy to follow up
with some resources and links would be
great thank you very
much representative Edwards for a
question uh thank you Mr chair um is is
is there a differential in eligibility
for this to where um two parent families
are as easily made eligible as single
family single parent families I I'm
curious um about what we're going to be
doing in the future supporting two
parent families more yep uh families in
both of those scenarios would be
supported eligible and could you get
closer to the mic I'm I'm just really
deaf and I and I talk softly so maybe
we're a bad
combination the uh both of those
scenarios families with two parents as
well as single parent families would be
eligible so for services and there would
certainly be no no bias or or edging
towards either both would be available
if if referred by providers or their
Hospital further
questions saying none I'll entertain a
motion to adopt
2415 was that whoever represent walner
moved I I did but you pick represent
Earth moved represent Edward second to
adopt
24154 further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppose
no okay thank
you next item will be
from Department of Natural cultural
resources um Trails Bureau I guess
anybody here from that department would
you please come forward to answer
question and introduce yourself
make sure when you get close to the mic
push the red button so we know it's
on there you
go Alexis rugco deputy chief for the
Bureau of trails uh Chris Marino Chief
Administration Senator rosenal had a
question I do thank you very much for
being here
um I know these are these monies are to
build new trip and our state parks and
I'm wondering why there's not a
requirement that new trails be
accessible to people with
walking problems IE
wheelchairs why are we making not making
it so that all of our residents have
access to our state
parks so that that's a good question
many of our trails that are built
there's different types there's ohrv
Trails snowmobile trails hiking trails
and such many of the trails that are
built especially ones in City centers
are accessible and we do look for that
in applications some Trails like a
hiking trail up the side of Mount
Washington isn't technically accessible
without an Adaptive
wheelchair follow follow up so
but to just
contain accessible trails to
cities doesn't really include all of our
residents in the great beautiful New
Hampshire outdoors and I'm sure there's
a middle ground between a city
street and Mount
Washington are these
Trails going to be at such a pitch that
it's not possible to make them
accessible many trails would be built to
be accessible the the the money is for
every single type of Trail in the entire
state so if somebody applied and wanted
to build an accessible Trail they can
build it there's nothing preventing them
from doing so it's just that not every
single Trail in the state is capable of
being an accessible Trail without
adaptive
equipment final question final question
what why why is the department not
requiring from the biders that where
appropriate the trails
be uh built in such a way to be
accessible to all of our
residents we actually do on the
application we have a whole section that
talks about um accessibility and
Community Partners that they work with
in order to build these trails we just
can't limit that that requirement to
every single Trail in the state cuz it
would exclude many of our OHV and
snowmobile trails throughout the state
as well as the more difficult hiking
trails that still need funds in order to
be maintained and upgraded These funds
are not limited to just new Trail
building it is for um maintaining
existing Trails as well and nobody is
restricted from those
Trails for applying I'm sorry I thought
it was a last question but if I get one
more so is the department going to
require that new trails be accessible or
just score them more highly on an
application it depends on where they
want to put the trail for example if
they want to build a new hiking trail up
the side of a mountain we can't require
them to make it accessible because it
wouldn't fit the location and the type
of trail that you're looking for many um
organizations like that that provide
accessible devices to users they can use
that to get up the trail they just
wouldn't be able to do it with a
motorized wheelchair because of the
terrain but when there are applications
where it would make sense and my example
of like a city center that's where we
would look for it we have denied some
applications in the past where it was a
location perfectly fit for an accessible
Trail the the town did not want to put
one in and it didn't score for high
enough against other Trail applications
that had that accessibility
component thank you do you have on your
website a list of accessible
Trails I don't believe so under the
Bureau of trails but there are external
organizations that do provide lists of
websites that oh sorry lists of
locations where accessible trails are
available for the wheelchair bound that
might be a good thing to have on your
website at least the link to those
places that have the list excellent
suggestion
okay Senator dallesandro thank thank you
Mr chair but is it the
goal to to make Trails
available to the greatest amount of
people in the state and and and visitors
so that they can enjoy them and they're
accessible is is that our goal in in
terms of when we when we offer these uh
what we offer grits so okay is is
specifically the
grit to take care of as many people as
possible to
provide the ability to use these
facilities that is exactly correct so we
look for applications specifically if
they are going to upgrade an existing
Trail to be accessible as well as if
they are going to build a new one to be
accessible those are the ones that we
score the highest so it is our goal okay
thank you thank you Mr chair further
discussion representative Edwards thank
you Mr chair I I I'd like to think that
what I've heard you say is that the
policy on using these Trail monies uh
includes a very wide diversity of Trail
access and that way by having the
diversity we're probably able to satisfy
the interests and needs of pretty much
all of our citizens
that not everything has to be for
everybody but the it's in the diversity
and the wide
availability uh that is sort of the
beauty of our trail
system that is certainly correct and
many of our residents who um do
participate in ohrv writing say that
it's a it's wonderful because they can
use the ohrv as their adaptive device so
they get to go to some of these more
difficult locations that they wouldn't
be able to do so in a wheel
chair further discussions on the item
I'll entertain a motion to
adopt 24
179 Senator dallesandro moves to approve
second by representative Lehman further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppos no the item is adopted moving
on to tab seven thank
you and we'll go to
item
24153 or Tab 8 rather excuse me tab
eight tab eight item
24153 Health and Human
Services excuse me uh representative
rosenwall for a question senator rosenal
for thank you very much good morning um
I notice um in this item that there's
50,000
for out ofate travel and we asked you
about it in Pre pref
fiscal um but the response was that
17 APS staff are going to go to a
three-day conference in
Albuquerque that works out to almost
$3,000 a person that just seems
like pretty high rate for travel costs
and I wonder if you could
elaborate on why it's so expensive to
get to Albuquerque and stay there for
three days yeah thank you for the
question um Melissa Hardy division
director for long-term supports and
services so the 17 staff from EPS would
be traveling on a Sunday so we still
have to um incur those costs for
Staffing from Sunday and then they would
return on Wednesday evening so it is
only three nights but it is a a long
extended period of time for 17 of our
staff that would need to be um
reimbursed for
that further question and there's also
in that 50,000 there's um we might have
the opportunity if that cost does come
down per person for additional staff to
attend training um for financial
exploitation there's a training that we
want to send staff to but all depends on
you know the cost of per person for that
annual training
anything further on the item
24153 seeing I'll entertain a motion to
approve second Senator Rosal moves to
approve representative Edwards seconds
to approve
24153 further discussion seeing none you
ready for the question all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted moving
on to item 24183
uh Department of administrative
Services hi I'm Charlie Arling housee
I'm the commissioner of administrative
services and we're in charge of
bathrooms thank you for coming
representative see Lehman for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question Commission
commissioner I see you're looking to get
at least a million dollars of arper
funds and the total projects about 2.1
million just to question why not ask for
additional arer funds because I guess
the rest of the money would have to come
from General funds if you don't have
another source of funds for the
renovation of the bathroom so this this
is a project that we're doing uh in
cooperation with the general court as
you might imagine and my understanding
is that the the request for funds came
directly from the uh members of the
general court or its staff to um gopher
and that um I don't know if they
requested the whole amount I suspect
they did and that um gopher must have
said we've got about a million bucks so
take it or leave it um it's my hunch
right and I didn't ask questions I just
said you know it's 2.1 million right
yeah yeah and and a guy named Terry said
um yeah that's how much we have and so I
think what we're plan on doing is
bathrooms are
scalable um yeah there are lots of
bathrooms we'll do as many as we can
it's that kind of thing and you have a
deadline that these funds must be or the
the construction must be finished by we
have to encumber we have to encumber the
money fully including a GNC contract by
the end of the calendar year um and I as
you might guess uh I have regular
updates with public works on all of the
construction projects and are we going
to make it or not and um I would say
that if you line line these up like the
trains on a car this is the Caboose but
I think the Caboose is going to make it
too thank you so just to followup if I
could Mr chairman seeing commissioner
Caswell in the audience maybe he could
answer why maybe they couldn't get the
total amount or whether that request was
made come
forward director Caswell thank you for
coming good morning uh I knew I should
have set in the back
um good morning so the request that we
received was actually $4 million it was
not for the $2.1 million that we
approved we what we received from the
general
court I guess we'll have to check on
that Mr chairman thank you okay further
discussion on the item
seeing none I'll entertain a motion to
approve
24183 motion by Senator
dallesandro second
by representative lean further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no that item is
adopted moving on to the regular
calendar on Tab 10
first item is Health and Human
Services are there any questions on item
24151 it's fairly routine uh
reapportionment I'll entertain a motion
to adopt item
24151 Senator alesandro moves
second represent Edward seconds to adopt
item
24151 further discussion seeing none all
in favor say I I oppose no that item is
adopted um tab
11 site evaluation
committee are there any questions on the
item
Senator do rosenal
yeah thank you very much introduce
yourselves
please I'm Drew Beamer the administrator
of the
SEC I'm Lenny Rdio the chief of
operations for Department of energy we
handle the administrative functions of
the SEC thank you my question was just
about the source of funds General funds
and I was Wonder wondering whether arpa
funds would have been usable and whether
you made a
request um the uh the statute that um
funds the SEC um provides for the
general funds in case that the SEC funds
are insufficient um it was never
contemplated to request um federal funds
for this ARA
funds further
discussion seeing now and attain a
motion to adopt the item
the all right motion to adopt item
24157 motion by rep by Senator
dallesandro second by Senator Pearl
further discussion seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor say I I
oppose no the item is adopted moving on
to AB 12 item 24 175
Department of Business and economic
Affairs any questions on this
item representa
lean we have director
Caswell we commissioner Taylor Caswell
business and economic
Affairs so I guess just to get it out
there because you've heard rumors that
we've heard about the status of the mill
in gorum which I guess can be dispelled
by what you have to offer for and I just
was glad to see manad Papermill was also
being a successful recipient of these
funds but if you could just tell us a
status and get rid of that rumor that's
been circulating about the mill up north
yes I'd be happy to uh representative
thank you so white mountain paper
company uh we did uh we've worked with
them very closely through this process
um I think at this point they're
employing around uh 73 individuals uh
they have uh just this year they expect
to begin operating in the black which
has been something they've struggled
with for a few years given the age of
the infrastructure and so on and that
they do intend this calendar year to add
another another line of paper
manufacturing at that facility so uh in
speaking with the with the ownership
yesterday just to confirm these figures
um they had um the owners themselves in
addition to the acquisition costs have
invested $9 million into this into their
uh revitalization project so that's
going quite well and I would say that if
you happen to be in the gorm area area
it would be worth asking to come by and
take a look they've done some
significant work there uh and that place
is probably looking about as good as it
has over the last 15 or 20 years in my
view very good thank you Mr chairman
further
questions I'll entertain a motion to
adopt the
item all right Lehman moves
Senator dallesandro second's adopt item
24175 is there further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose no the
item is
adopted we have several light
items that we will now bring up I hope
everyone has
them I think I have them all in the same
order first one being 24
1997 and that
has some history that I observed
Wednesday night at the public
meeting
so the one of the items was withdrawn
but this one Still Remains this deals
with the
U funds
to to uh transfer the the
personnel and we have director white
here to answer any
questions
CFO represent rosenal then represent
alandro thank you Mr chairman um U my
question really isn't about why we're
switching providers
I understand that I think it's great uh
my question is why was item 198
withdrawn which would have repaid
Hampton for some Hampstead for some
extra cost and secondly when does the
department plan to bring that item
back sure um so just just for context
and awareness uh for everyone here um
apologize Nathan white Chief fin
Financial Officer Department of Health
and Human Services um over the past two
State fiscal years and state fiscal year
23 and state fiscal year year 24 the
department paid approximately
$178,000 to the town of Hamstead for
payment and L of taxes um currently SB
311 I believe was just passed uh out of
house finance um with with arpa funds
available for the appropriation of the
equivalent amount of
154,000 um and directing the department
to make a payment of 193,000 the reason
or 191 um the reason for that being
essentially the equivalent amount of tax
loss to the town
um we do anticipate bringing forward the
item in June um from a process
perspective there is no impact because
no payment would be made in still the
state fiscal year 25 at this point so
thank
you repres representative Edwards for a
question um thank you I I participated
in the passing of SP 311 uh the question
that was brought up that I was not able
to answer while we were talking about it
is is what is the Department's long-term
Vision on continuing that uh that
payment in Li of property taxes is this
something we expect to do forever do we
expect a five-year transition what what
are we what are we wanting to do with
this sure and and I I I think I would um
just call back to the conversation that
that we had I believe during the public
hearing with the Full House Finance as
well as the the work session with
division 3 in the sense that um I think
that's a larger policy discussion uh for
the next budget process um because uh
what occurred during this budget process
was during the Senate phase the Senate
appropriated and directed the department
to um to make payments to the town of
Hamstead uh that particular provision
didn't make it to the final budget there
was no commed a conference so there was
never a discussion between the house and
the Senate relative to that topic in
question um so I would anticipate that
we would need to have a more longer term
discussion relative to the long-term
implications and direction of the state
on that front follow up um with us just
starting the governor's budget process
here in the next few weeks if you
wouldn't mind keeping a Post-It note to
ask the governor's office what they
think they we ought to be doing from a
policy perspective long term I'd like to
you know figure out what we need to do
to you know support the the best policy
or or or or not but thanks of
course further
discussion just a question Mr
chairman represent Senator dallesandro
thank you Mr chairman tell tell me about
the transition between wellsense and the
new
provider you got a June 30th deadline
right that's when the uh wellsense
leaves and uh Dartmouth comes in how
about this transition how's it going to
take place and is it going to be smooth
in terms of the people the people that
are involved how many will reate how
many are be let go the story
there and and and the service because as
we know the town has been
uh let's say quite vociferous in in
terms of the
entity good morning Lori Weaver
commissioner Health and Human Services
um in regards to uh the transition um it
is a short period of time to transition
a hospital uh Nathan is and team are
working fastidiously to uh tie up all
those details um 7:30 this morning I
went met with the Hamstead staff I'll be
down there this afternoon as well for
two sessions with the staff as well to
talk about what it means and what it
doesn't mean um but the main message is
to keep doing the good with the work
that they're doing and staying focused
on running the hospital um hospitals in
running is in good shape under the
leadership of Justin luier who has been
um tremendous since he came on board so
leaning a lot on him for that transition
I would like to think that for patient
care it's a seamless transition um and
that the staff don't know any different
even though there's a lot of moving
Parts okay just one further question
further question and and Have you
communicated with the town about the
about the the uh about the transition
and sort of some in some way allayed
their fears or that seemed to have
manifested themselves at that meeting
that took place at
hiet I will be 100% honest and say we
did try to communicate with the town we
have communicated with the town um I
think Wednesday night was a little
difficult because we weren't given or
afforded a lot of opportunity to speak
we were asked to listen and I think we
did do a lot of listening um we've done
a lot of listening we'll continue to do
a lot of listening um the the town
meeting was really to be focused on the
new YDC build um and I think uh often we
heard about issues uh or concerns about
the hospital but uh and those questions
are answered but uh there's ongoing
communication with Town officials um on
a regular basis from Justin from Team
from my department from myself from
Marissa hen um so I feel that yes we are
open we are listening and we're trying
to be heard as well okay thank you thank
you Mr CH Senator rosenal thank you Mr
chair can you tell us when the perimeter
fence will be installed
as soon as all it's state government and
paperwork right we have the funding
we're putting forth the um uh Justin
putting forth the estimates if you will
so what we attempted to present to the
town on Wednesday night was the the
diagram of what the perimeter fence
would look like and what the actual
fence would look like so that people
could see what it would look like we
didn't unfortunately have the
opportunity to do that so I think we're
expecting um probably within the next 3
to 6 months it's getting the bids and
going through the process that we have
to go through but we're working on that
as soon as possible thank
you a question about the transition are
you just matching the pay that the
people are presently getting are you
fitting them into a state system are you
how how are you doing this is there a
pay raise a pay loss or equal pay it
would be equal pay we're not looking to
raise their pay or or harm them by
having pay loss so we're trying to do
comparable pay um and benefits um
package for them which is what we're
working on right now will it become
problematic if someone that's say an irn
with three years experience ends up with
more money on this deal than an irn with
three years experience somewhere else in
the state those are the bumps that we're
trying to uh smooth out right now they
are a represented environment so we will
be looking at uh their bargaining pieces
with that as well and where that falls
in um but we have to outweigh weigh all
of that but like I said it's a quick
transition so we need we need a minute
to smooth that out I don't have all the
answers of what what it is at this time
all right we're pleased that it's moving
forward uh I'll entertain a motion to
approve 24 1997 second Senator rosemal
moves to approve representative Edwards
seconds further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppos no that item
is adopted thank
you moving on to uh item 2419
3 again the governor's office of
emergency relief and Recovery director c
cwell f are there any questions on the
item I'll entertain my item
second Senator gray moves to approve
24193 Senator Bradley seconds further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no that item is
approved moving on to P International R
International Development
Authority item
24194 I'll move it I got a question all
right we have a motion from Senator
Bradley a second by Senator gray and
introduce yourself we have a question uh
good morning miles Greenway assistant
Port
director Senator Dallas Sandra for a
question right thank you thank you for
coming what is going on at at the at the
Port Authority with regard to to the
director goo marcot we've we've heard
nothing and and uh I've had a brief
conversation uh with him and what what
is what is his status at this point in
time who is running the port who's
running it sir right now I've been uh
selected to be the acting Port director
uh director Marone has been put on
administrative leave with pay until
further notice during investigation and
that's really all the information I have
as well
sir
just he's on he's on leave with pay
pending an investigation yes
sir does the public know anything about
this
investigation nothing more than that was
put in the local newspapers and that uh
our executive director has given a
statement on and just that's the
information I have as well
sir
uh that's a questionable situation I I
would think maron's got been there for a
long period of time uh been very
involved been very involved with many of
the with all of the operations and we
got another item that's that's coming
before us today the this slate item for
uh something that's happening at the
port Authority and uh when when will we
know when will the public when will the
legislature know what's going on in
peace I don't have that answer sir I
will say that this is something that
director Marone has been in works with
for a long time for the dredging project
and to support with the Army Corp of
engineer right I understand that the the
dredging part project is very important
and completing it is very important I
understand that thank you thank you Mr
chair thank you justice delayed as
Justice and night he should know by now
why he's been removed
sir
so there's he's got a lot of support
he's come before us for many times in
the Years we're all impressed with his
knowledge and we distress at what's
happening I hope you would bring that
back to the to the board sir we would
like to have a little more information
when a valued employee is mistreated in
our eyes understand I'll entertain an a
motion to it okay we have an we have we
have a second and a a motion in a second
to adopt any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no dring item is adopted
thank you thank
you treatment is
better next item is FIS
24195 Department of Health and Human
Services again I'll move the item second
okay a motion
by okay motion by uh Senator Bradley
second
by Senator gray to adopt item 24 195 is
there any further discussion just a
question question from Senator
dallesandro thank you uh uh here we have
a situation where money is coming to
Manchester for homeless which is very
important yet uh this we needed this
money uh long to have before today what
what what took it so long to get
here so good morning for the record I'm
Kya Fox I am the director of the
division for Behavioral Health this um
uh particular request is coupled with SB
um which was introduced and has gone
through the legislative process which
was to increase the rates for shelters
the legislature and Governor um did
appropriate an increase for shelter bed
rates through this uh banial budget this
will further that rate increase this
additional amount it was identified
through the legislative process for SB
406 that these funds could be made
available to further increase those
rates and that is what is before you
today okay thank
you Senator Bradley then Senator Rosal
so miss Fox is absolutely correct the
bed rate
was uh I think about $8 we increased it
to $20 in the budget last year there was
testimony that came in in the hearing
process on Senate bill
406 um from different shelters that
absent a second rate increase to about
$27 that shelters would have to close
during the summer months um problematic
so we in the Senate process and we were
all involved in this um amended Senate
Bill 406 to um change from a new program
to enhanced rates for for uh these beds
and in discussion with the governor he
thought it was um a good way to fund
this and it can be done uh sooner with
more certainty through this process
which is why I commend uh the department
for bringing this forward thank
you Senator rosemal thank you Mr
chairman um so I sometimes hear rumors
about what's going on in
Manchester but I think I heard that the
city of Manchester
decreased its own funding for
shelters so could you please tell us to
what extent this money is actually
increasing shelter
funding in Manchester because I also
heard that one of the that one of the
shelters maybe the biggest one might
have to close during this
summer so thank for the questions which
um I can't answer specifically about the
city of Manchester and the level of
funding that they currently have in any
contemplation of a decrease in that
amount we do know that Manchester um
does have um
an burden of many people who are in
their City who are um Without Shelter
and uh as far as closures go there has
been no direct contact with the
Department about a potential closure um
however we did hear from the shelters
through the hearing processes that
they're are very they're very concerned
about their ability to continue to serve
the people that present before them and
that they are at capacity in the middle
of right now they're at capacity uh so
this will help uh one of the areas that
they have concerns about is to be able
to maintain staff um um so that they can
keep the capacity that they have and
have that utilization stay where it's at
thank you follow up follow of question
um it's really more for commissioner
Caswell
um I see that the explanation says if
arpa funds are not available General
funds will be
requested and so my question is will
arpa funds be available
or are we going to be appropriating
General funds I don't have sorry uh I
don't have the the item right in front
of me um but for these items here we did
um ad language that referred to the
availability of funding to be
reallocated from um oh here we go
uh so uh this item and some of the
others do have a line there at the
beginning that refers to the
availability of funding under the arpa
sfrf program for reallocation so we are
at a point right now where we don't have
all the reallocations to be able to fund
these projects uh right out of the box
but what's happening right now is that
um one of the items either you've
already approved or um or is coming up
extends the spending authorization for a
large number of projects that are being
funded using arpa dollars there are some
other projects that are not going to be
extended and at that point those
projects and those funds will lapse back
to gopher and that's when we'll be able
to uh have an idea as to exactly how
much funding will be available and then
that that would fund these items several
of these items that are on this list
today follow so I mean we basically are
at the point where we're making vending
decisions in committee do you know when
you will know if oura funds will be
available to cover this and there's a I
think another item that's larger that
yes I could say that we would know uh
once we pass the end of the fiscal year
exactly which of those uh how much of
those funds will be able to be
reallocated the reason is that the
projects that are not going to be
extended with their spending Authority
and we did this quite deliberately to be
able to have this room to be able to
maneuver once before we get to the um
the obligation deadline at the end of
this year um the uh once we uh those
programs will lose their spending
Authority but they have between now and
then to continue to spend those funds so
we don't know exactly what that amount
will be until we reach June 30th thank
you representative ER for question thank
you Mr chair a couple of questions so is
this $25 million of ARA funding in
addition to the $25 million of ARA
funding and SB
406 the uh 2.5 million um authorization
request here would fund s SP 406 so it's
not an addition to it would support that
bill follow up and a separate question
I assume you have to basically enter
into agreements with the various
communities that would receive this this
boost in the in the funding do you
anticipate those being one-time boosts
in in in the agreements that that's a
really good question we do anticipate uh
funding providing the funding to the
current um contracted shelters and then
would um need to through the budget
process to maintain those rates need to
be request those
funds represent Edwards for a question
uh thank you Mr chair
um I've been generally sympathetic to
the request to uh increase funding uh
for our homeless shelters and um and
I've been doing it on the hope that uh
the homeless shelters will be able to
continue the transition services that
they've been offering during the daytime
and uh I had I was concerned concerned
when we were told that if they didn't
get the money um they one of the things
that they would ask would be the
transition Support Services during the
day and to me that's sort of the magic
sauce of converting a a cot at night to
a transition program which would be
better so having said all of that now
that we're giving the money do we have
any um expectations do we have anything
uh any assurances really that these
transition services are going to remain
in
effect again a great question case
management is such a key component to
this because we want uh people to be
engag in services and have these be just
very short stays the uh contractors are
required to provide those Case
Management Services so any contemplation
of ending those Services would need to
go through through the department and um
any negotiation or um for us to take
action
on representative Lehman for a question
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question so it says that about 940
beds would be uh paid for through these
existing
contracts how many more do we need I
gathered from your response earlier that
this is a a shortfall for what's needed
out there so I'm just curious if you the
department has any idea of the number of
shelters beds that are needed for those
that are
homeless I do not actually have a number
to be able to give to you we do know
that um capacity is a significant issue
across the state but in some communities
more so than others um and that
typically we have um had to back into
the number that we are provided to
support these shelters and for the
systems to be able to respond to uh
requests for proposals uh based on what
they think is uh adequate to be able to
stand up and maintain those services so
I do not have a number um of of what is
needed but I know that we're currently
at capacity pretty much across the state
every day just phip do you have any just
a guess I know you you're always very uh
tactful as far as your responses but do
you have like a a guess that I'll short
we are as far as providing shelters well
the applications that towns and cities
put in there must be a number out there
that we do have our um point in time
counts and that uh determines how many
uh people who are sheltered um
unsheltered Etc and I'd be happy to Prov
provide those numbers and then we can
see where those match up but there still
is a Delta um and as we know right now
in New Hampshire with housing being so
tight it is really difficult um so what
our needs are today may be different in
a different um economic situation thank
you thank you Mr chairman further
discussion Senator Rosal thank you so
I'm just trying to get clarity on this
we go out of session on June 13th
the commissioner um told us that he
won't know
until after the end of the fiscal year
if those arpa funds are available so if
Senate Bill 406 goes forward and
appropriates $2.5 million of General
funds and we also
appropriate $2.5 million today of arpa
and or general
funds what would happen is the
Department's plan to spend $5 million
extra on homeless services
or what would happen given the
legislative
calendar I can comment if you want
Nathan I can sure um so Mike Michael
Kane legislative budget assistant so
senator rosem sener Bill 406 as it's
passed uh is being proposed by house
finance uh has an appropriation language
in in tiers so first it would be arpa
fund $25 million so the governor is
first directed to look at arpa funds and
then any remainder would be General
funds it's not going to be in addition
to whatever is approved here if it is
approved it will be um that will take
the place of that in the event that um
this is not approved that and that bill
still goes forward there's option at the
governor at that point to identify ARA
funds or to appropriate General funds so
uh how that language is drafted is to
for 2 and a half million for this entire
problem total
yes further
discussion
it's it's already okay motion of second
has already been made um are there any
further discussions on item 24195 seeing
none you're ready oh if you're ready for
the question profession all in favor say
I I oppose no that item is
adopted moving on
to 24
1996 second all right a motion from
Senator dallis Sandro second by Senator
gray to approve item 24 196 further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no that item is adopted
that completes our late item I
believe moving on to the informational
item are there any
questions I I'd like to ask one on um
the statistics page when we get to that
okay is that can you refer I I think
it's uh 160 okay 24 160 that'd be the uh
operating the dashboard yes
sir Health and Human Services
so I'm going to continue um a theme and
that is uh my concern over the sizing of
this new new use Services Center
replacement we put it at 12 with a
maximum capacity at 18 and as I'm
looking at the average daily
sentences uh we are running um 3/4 of a
year at 18 or above
uh even on those 18 months we had to
have days where we were over 18 to in
order to average out to be 18 so so so
fundamentally I think we have to ask a
strategic question did did we under
siize underestimate the capacity of the
replacement Center and if so what's the
smartest thing to do about
that hello again uh just for the record
the census this week is
14 just for the record as of yesterday
the census was 14 at at at sunon Center
so um you know we're looking at the
averages uh in the report here and we
have seen an increase particularly in uh
23 which is different than when you're
looking at anything um in 22 and and
earlier than that um I think you know we
based at the time that we had the
legislation on what the average was and
the aage was around 12 knowing that we
could Flex up to 18 we are seeing an
increase in the amount of committed
children versus detained children there
so right now more than 50% of that 14 is
committed so those kids are there longer
so we are working on the system on the
back end right now um with all of our
stakeholders including the courts to
look at why why is that happening why
are more kids being committed and and
are there other ways to divert them from
the system uh rather than the Comm or is
it more that more detained and less
committed so we're actively engaged
behind the scenes to try to systemically
look at what's happening there and Trend
that in a different direction so it's
hard to say did we under bed or over bed
we we can only go with the numbers that
we've had we know that over the last two
years we've had a 50% decrease in kids
coming into the system overall in the
juvenile justice system not just YDC so
we know we're trending in the right
direction for that but yet we have seen
it increase here so that's you know
that's what we're trying to to work at
right now and get our hands
on followup um so so what I think I just
heard you say is that we don't yet think
and we may not ever think that we've
made a strategic error in uh undersizing
the capacity that that we don't know yet
uh in if it becomes possible that did um
I would encourage you to try to engage
the legislature earlier rather than
later and to um that that's sort of my
concern I I'm as accountable as almost
anyone for the sizing of 12 to 18 and so
I I'm willing to own it if we undersized
it but uh I need I need you all to give
us the red flashing light if it happens
we'll do
yes did you want to reply oh my reply
was will do I'm sorry okay I missed it
thank you further further
discussion any other questions on the
dashboard seeing none what other items
in the
information groupings would people like
to question
if that's not a problem
then I guess we're down to next
meeting I have a
uh I have a county meeting in
June that should be
finalized on the 19th
however the backup date if we don't get
a quorum is the 21st in the morning
which is the third
Friday that that may never happen but I
have to be ready to have it happen if if
I don't have a quorum on the
19th which is
46 State reps so is there any objection
to moving it to Thursday the 20th
is that a problem for
anybody Mr
Kane we're okay with any date just you
choose I guess most of our legislative
work should be done by then I hope
so all
right what time on on Thursday we want
it later in the day you want it about
same time o' what time 10
o'clock all right 10 o'clock Thursday
the 20th for
fiscal thank you very much that will be
our next M next
meeting is there anything further to
come before the fiscal committee Mr Kane
anything you know of
no wow that was a quick
meeting must be the skill of the
chair motion to adjourn
all in favor we are adjourned thank you
very much thank you all for your
attendance